I in all seriousness I've kind of grown
up with his face and it's been in the
industry for ten years
and that's getting on these hottie lists
I just got to go right doesn't make any
sense because I was knowing it a
thousand hottest face when I started out
so I know it's I know a lot of its
projection which is which is kind of
flattering about the work I suppose I
think just to begin with I'm curious do
you remember the first time you acted in
any capacity even just fun around the
house or something and then was there a
moment or an instant or something after
which you knew that this was what you
were gonna do with your life I think
anyone who's been the mother of children
should really answer that question I
probably acted up when I was very very
young and too young to remember but um
as far as doing stuff at school I think
my first memory was being a town crier
in a weird sort of fairytale fantasy and
I I remember one of the reasons our
remembers there was a video of it and I
am I came on the middle of stage and
clash these big symbols and sort of
announced very proudly what was about to
happen or that part of the story just
sort of moving the narrative on but when
I watch the back of the video I just I
did that and then I stopped in the
middle of the stage whilst the other
people coming on and just turned around
and looked at it instead of getting off
stage but I mean there's my early acting
memories probably that and I remember it
being a big hole I can't remember where
it was but it felt big and quite scary
so yeah I think that's honestly my first
memory although I'm often reminded of a
time when I was on in a nursery play and
I played Joseph and apparently happy I'm
you saw a lot of clips of me getting
very angry so maybe that was a seed for
it because apparently I pushed Mary off
stage because she was taking too long
which and then a poor Mary who ever was
everyone laughed I mean it terrible and
I haven't that done that to a leading
lady sensing what kara maybe a bit in in
the imitation game but you know I'm
joking
well you know people may or may not know
that you went and got a master's degree
at at the professional theatre of the
London Academy of Music and Dramatic Art
I just wonder if you can talk about what
what the biggest takeaway from that was
and also I know you know often actors
are asked to describe their method or
the technique approach and I know that
you have a
opinion about this which was interesting
interestingly reinforced by one of your
co-stars so I would just like to ask you
about that um
I mean I'd I try not to go in with one
specific technique because every job is
it's so unique in its different
requirements so there's a focus and
there's an understanding and approach to
work which is sort of universe on there
there are Givens there are you know
there are there are certain parameters
you have to work in as an actor and
sometimes they're the hardest to
maintain timekeeping is one of them and
I'm the Taurus about of that and
learning your lines and I'm alright at
that at times and sometimes it can get
overwhelming it with especially that
clip you saw at the end with that
character he's quite for baisha so there
are good days and bad days but yeah I
would say that it's just I've always
felt instinctively that it would limit
the range of the work that you are
capable of doing if you had one method
that you imposed on everybody else that
you're collaborating with and so
obviously as a student actually first I
got my MA at Manchester I think it's an
MA lambdas Oh but I'm not sure it was
really a postgraduate one-year course
I'm not even sure I got an MA though I
think there was more to do with
Manchester I did three years of drama
and an awful lot of plays an awful lot
of acting but an awful lot of other
things around that which fed into the
acting and I think that started my kind
of understanding that it's part of a
total art form it's not just something
in isolation because I was studying I
don't know everything from sort of
post-world war ii american theater to
dramas therapy and prisons of probation
to writing courses to sort of early
russian revolutionary cinema I mean
Russian Revolution cinema and it just
gave me appreciation of context and I
think from that it gave me an
appreciation of what the duty is to kind
of also the enjoyment of further
education as an actor to further
research your role so I went into drama
school with that and and of course
lambda
like many drama schools don't various
approaches very
you know the inside out or the outside
in but for the first time I realized
after maybe I don't know maybe ten years
or something of playing all sorts of
different roles especially after my
voice finally broke when I was about I
don't know 22 I'd played a lot of girls
I was young I played Rosalind and Kate
and I don't they came to me the show
played Petrucci over and last I play
titania and Queenie the fairies that was
my debut at the all-boys boarding school
I went to and but I I realized that I
had to be a version of myself and you
never fully escaped yourself you always
partly there of course you are new in
the limits of your own body to an extent
so it's about it's about understanding
that you can do the hatbox stuff you can
have great fun doing everything from
playing crapping Krapp's Last Tape aged
22 to Arthur Willy Loman rather in Death
of a Salesman at 17 - Rosalind aged 15
literally two years before and and have
fun with that you know really really
kind of diversify what you what you want
to try and change yourself into but
drama school taught me about just being
still and centered and having a very
kind of measured approach to text to not
jump the gun to sit in the words for
longer not not jump to intuition all the
time or at least if you had that first
instinct that you could then work a long
way around it to come back full circle
to that initial feeling of understanding
a character or a moment or an objective
obstacle Tova karma and it employed that
language so you know you did all this
stuff you get on acting page one and and
that was really useful just to just to
put the brakes on it just evaluate where
I was with that my real understanding of
it and not just skim over it which
obviously I think we had done a lot at
school and have you when you've worked
with various interesting alright he's
trying to please try to get me to say
when I work with Meryl Streep
first bit of name-dropping in the
evening but um I uh you know she and I
had this conversation because I was
watching her bring virus into life and I
was going how the [ __ ] is she doing that
she's playing she's playing grief she's
playing esophageal cancer she's playing
the effects of the cancer drugs or not
the drugs she's playing the uppers and
downers that she's taking and she's
playing everything that's been boiling
in her since a child since an abused
child being an abuse calendar
I just saw this actress at the height of
her powers being able to play every
single note of her character like not
even a conductor of an orchestra but
like she was literally running around
and playing every instrument and it was
really phenomenal and I thought how the
hell did you begin what was the first in
and - did you work from the outside and
this one and she Benny we had a
cigarette was election night and we were
chatting about the Bacchus I've got to
ask you I'm just it's wonderful watching
you work and how how did how do you
start do you have a base that you always
build from and she went what do you mean
like a specific technique um and I would
yeah edge when no I think you know I
think it changes all the time oh my god
my god it's to hear someone say that
because that's that's what I do that's
that's what I'd always done and simply
for the reasons that I think it keeps
you it keeps you able to adapt your
craft to learn from those around you and
so yeah there some jobs that are much
more like the method than others I mean
I work with Katie Mitchell and the
theatre and she said she provides such
an intense process you don't need to
have gone to acting school in order to
be able to be in one of her productions
she gives you such a kind of complex
multi multiple ed multiple ed kind of
focal point to to hook your character on
whether it's the temperature of the room
whether it's the sound that the
neighbor's dogs just made whether it's
the memory that the photograph that's
not even on the set but that you've
talked about in rehearsal is giving you
as you look across the room to the
counter to the left of the wife you're
talking to lying about the fact that
you've been fired I mean just all this
stuff to the point that we got to first
night and it was a real shot coming an
audience for a start it was just like
what you know that happened and I was
like what that's not funny because in my
mind that's something very very
different
and then once that was played in it was
it was wonderful you just really had a
not disregard for the one it's much much
though she's criticized for that it
really isn't what she's about to she
just builds a dolls house and lifts to
one of the walls off and I I've always
I've always loved watching her work and
thrilled to be a part of it and I really
the first time in my life didn't fear
judgment on the press tonight I thought
to hell with it I've got that's really
what it all should be about anyway you
know you should just be committing to
the work and not worrying about the
perception of it you've made that
compact with the director and your
fellow actors and it's about carrying
that through and it's not just about
personalities about building to that
last performance every day you you're
making new discoveries and moving it
forwards within certain confines your
character you've got certain tactics you
can employ to overcome your obstacles
but you can't just suddenly bring in
something you could do as another
character you can't just deduce the [ __ ]
out of it like Sherlock if you're
someone who has a little lower IQ and is
not so kind of focused as that man is
and so you know I eat that was
extraordinary and I took a lot from that
and the seeds of that were in drama
school but beyond that yeah that was
that was the first real calling where I
went wrong I can I can escape into
something that's so focused that I sort
of become lost in my task rather than
self-conscious about what the effects of
what I'm doing is going to be on an
audience and in terms of just on a
day-to-day level what do you feel brings
out the best in you would you be
somebody who responds well to a lot of
rehearsal or prefers not to would you be
somebody who on in the case of film or
TV you know if you can if you're asked
to do many takes is that something you
appreciate it you know sometimes people
say it maybe take some of the
spontaneity out of it where do you fall
I think a lot of takes yeah I'm really
bad at that I mean it doesn't mean that
I do a lot of good takes it just means I
like doing it politics but I mean I
don't know and various rhythms come in
with different characters in a situation
so some directors have said your third
your best first as a warm-up second
you're getting used to it and the third
you is good and then everything else
you're trying to chase that third one
but I mean other other jobs it's the
18th sometimes I can't remember what I
my record is it
it's pretty heinous whatever it is but
it as far as warehouse who goes to go
back to the first part the question
absolutely I mean when it comes to film
and television as a luxury especially
television but it's sort of essential
because you you get to a point where you
have some concrete grounding for what
you're then stepping into so you can
tackle the day's work when there are
going to be technical difficulties
running out of time or light or cameras
not working or whatever it may be then
you're you and you have to just hit the
ground running have that in you and also
you can play you can have fun you can
evolve it because you know you've got
that kind of bedrock of preparation and
also that you're in collaboration with
everyone else you're working with you're
not on a solo flight and that's really
rewarding and again I suppose that comes
back slightly to method I think if
you're for me if I'm locked off doing my
own thing in there's certain days we
have to do that the brig scene in Star
Trek I just I couldn't play scramble
with friends with Zack and Chris I had
to go and I got to go into my corner to
think about my [ __ ] and why that's more
important than Bechet I mean nobody just
sorry well so articulate but you know
it's that thing of just being in
opposition to people you can't sometimes
you have to build a little bit of a
cocoon of concentration the second of
the third series of Sherlock I have this
massive monologue in the wedding scene
and that was it's intercut with loads of
flashbacks but it's basically a sort of
schizophrenic one-man show and I we did
it for five days I really had to pull
myself out of any kind of jollity which
of which there was a lot I mean an awful
lot it was great fun they had a lot of
fun without me so when you first entered
the work force as a professional actor
what sort of a career did you envision
for yourself as far as balancing it or
not balancing it between theatre versus
television versus film and then can you
take us back to the decision that came I
think maybe three four years ago where
you were offered an opportunity to go to
Broadway with a play that you'd already
been a part of and made a very it was a
very difficult decision for you but you
elected not to do that because of sort
of an idea of where you want to take
things so it was very so
which decision as well because it
affected a lot of other people I did do
it eight months before we were supposed
to go but apologies to Nancy Carol and
Adrian Scarborough and Thea Sharrock I
just wanted to mix it up all the time I
really wanted I wanted to I'm in my
theater training Atlanta was a classical
theater classically English theater one
year course and a postgraduate course
which I really enjoyed and got a lot out
of but you know it would that was it
that was the main focus because I
thought a little bit old-fashioned in my
kind of understanding of it I thought
that what I do what the great actors
that have been ahead of me had done and
inspired me to do was the idea of
starting out in the classics then maybe
a modern play or two and a few roles in
television and then you know getting a
film role but keep going back to theater
and that is what I've done that is kind
of what I've tried to do the unhappy
accident of that play being such a huge
success was it came at a point where I
thought Christ I've actually got some
momentum in a medium where it's much
more of a closed door there's a very
little long-term memory it's much more
immediate your currencies something you
really have to kind of work on in film
quite fast to a to a degree I'm saying
this in cogitate everything I say
tonight is contradict but I know that
but it's just I guess that's what the
personal conversation is really it's
just a point of view but I am every time
I say anything I'm thinking the opposite
is also very true that's the kind of
yeah that's my head you're getting into
my head it's great being me so yeah I am
I really I was really lucky to have just
had a few breaks
obviously with Charlotte but also Tinker
Tailor also with Frankenstein and being
cast in warhorse and that all came to
the same kind of point where we were
supposed to be coming here to do this
Broadway production of after the dance
which might still happen might be a film
we don't know it might it's something
there might be some life left in it it
was a wonderful experience in London but
I felt that I'd had that experience
there and selfishly I wanted to make
some capital out of this momentum that
was building and I I'm glad I did
because I got Star Trek and job visa
slaving or was Osage County and yeah it
were he worked out well for me but um
and and and the Fifth Estate so I kind
of um I was very
yeah I took a gamble and it paid off
really so that decision as you say led
to all these other roles where that have
only further raised your profile since
then and one of the byproducts of that I
thought I want to ask you about is
clearly you know you are now a
conservatively more famous person than
you were at the beginning of this and I
wonder how that impacts you as an actor
because correct me if I'm wrong but it
seems to me that part of what makes many
actors great actors is the ability to
kind of go out observe other people
behaving as they as they do and
channeling that and when you become
quite famous I think that it made me
make that loan yeah so I mean does that
make your life harder as an actor
there are ways of their ways of
remaining disguised in plain sight as
gel it would say but the you know to be
honest there are a lot of famous actors
who are still doing great work so
they're obviously managing to observe
something of real life however bizarre
there's get but yeah it was a concern in
a sense but I'm what I value more than
that is privacy and I there are means
and ways to extract yourself enough to
be able to observe human nature and work
through whatever medium of research or
understanding of character or the human
condition that it is you need to be able
to get that and surprisingly you know
some of us do take public transport
still I've got a motorbike as well and I
Drive a car sometimes but I you know
it's not exclusive to the world of
everybody else but I know what you mean
it's it's now more about being conscious
of this sort of thing we're not I think
a private conversation I thought we were
comes in everyone but you know that's
where that is where then you know you're
constantly at the kind of mercy of
people who are basically with
smartphones walking publishers so you
kind of you under being a performer
understanding what a camera is and what
being observed is I'm very highly
attuned to that so you're right to
switch that focus back so that I'm the
one doing the watching is is is it is a
new craft for me but I'm managing it and
there are still corners of the world
that don't know who the hell I am so
that's that's always good but um there
are also an incredibly supportive amount
of people that recognize me but let me
Carrie
my business and it's fine it's just a
sort of skill I guess to balance and
it's interesting I mean I've got friends
here tonight and you know they've seen
this sort of change where but you know
in it basically and one of them said
that we said you know they'll night [ __ ]
unless I'm actually in my house with
your you and your house and I with you I
don't get you because there's always
always going to be some of the wants to
interact have a conversation or thing
always happened last night we're in a
restaurant and this screen just got
pushed aside there was a flash bugger
off my face and I was like wow that's
that's a first
I always lock the toilet door that's
what I mean you should anyway yeah but
yeah and I don't know yeah it's weird it
is with it is it is it's a it's a
learning process and I'm in fact my
infancy of it but you know I think some
of its helped by the fact it's happened
in my mid to late 30s so you know
there's a there's a sort of perspective
which kind of gives ability to breathe
and try and extract yourself a little
bit from the madness and say no and just
learn that you know you can politely
decline something and you'll just step
back a little bit but also how to engage
as well and I'm more comfortable to my
own skin that I would have been out
that's happened 10 years ago without a
doubt so and in that way it's a blessing
yeah so I don't know the exact
chronological order when you did these
things but in the past year we have seen
you apart from Sherlock in feather state
hobbit 12 years of slave August Osage
County goat season well Thursday's sure
like and star trek into darkness and
it's just it's just unbelievable in one
year you can't clearly it's hard to even
imagine how busy you must have been and
so I wonder you know do you do anything
specific between projects to sort of
cleanse the palate in a way or are you
able to jump from one thing into
something completely different
relatively seamlessly I I formed a
production company I did a short film
that was hardly cleansing the palette
but I know I do I try to I've been
really fortunate and it's a very
high-class problem to have but it is
it's increasingly difficult than
something I want to try and change in my
work pattern whereby
you know the last sort of - - I mean
this is a bumper crop of five months
worth of film releases coming out from
about one and a half years work but in
those one and a half and two years
before a lot of projects had dovetails
and that's kind of that always makes me
anxious because they're not not for fear
of repetition although there is always
that fear but I always choose one of the
criterias only way for my choice of work
is is to have variation you know
selfishly just to keep myself amused and
to stimulate myself in a different way
so even though I don't know I had a bank
holiday weekend between the end of the
third series of Sherlock and parade's
end and before Sherlock I just I
literally got off stage having at this
right yeah I got a stage four on
Frankenstein I think had about a week
before we started filming Sherlock I was
pretty damaged after Franco sign both
Johnny and I were pretty beat up so not
ideal but they're very different
characters very very different
characters and it was really weird this
I'd literally was picked up in a car on
our last night from the National Theatre
our after party got in a car driven down
to Strathfield say where we were filming
I was on set on a horse charging with 80
other horses it sort of 8:00 in the
morning with spill go Spielberg going
that was great want to do it again
that's great and just going yeah yeah I
think I do just sort of slide he's
performing off my saddle but I mean such
a different kind of Russian and
experience to finishing a place of being
on that kind of a set with live animals
I mean you cannot compare the
experiences and it was like what after
the what what what play was that you
know so it was that's the most sort of
intense turnaround I think I've had
ideally yeah and I think it's important
you should have and I try now to have a
shedding period of a bit of time so I
just get rid of the last one start
having some fun then I just sort of
Center and go back to neutral and find
out who I am friends and family very
handy for that as is travel and just
isolation from the madness of it all in
any shape or form and and then ya start
rubbing it up for the next one just
slowly cooking the reading and thinking
about what the challenges are going to
be speaking to people they know more
about my character than I could ever
possibly dream of knowing and relying on
the brilliance of the outside in stuff
with it whether it be wardrobe or
Aramaic
and and then obviously the collaboration
all the way through that with a director
and conversation in person and in
rehearsal hopefully at this time that's
the ideal that very rarely happens but I
mean you know it would be good it
happens every night again but yeah and
particularly I think with with you
played a number of people who were real
who are in many cases still alive and
you know going back to Stephen Hawking
right through Julian Assange and others
in between I just wonder how from what I
gather your real real real researcher
will do a lot of preparation and but yet
in some cases you seem to have met with
the person in other cases you elected
not to or you couldn't or whatever I
just how do you approach it differently
when it is somebody who who is a real
person most recently Asajj well there
two things I suppose that are immediate
very obvious which is there's a moral
responsibility because that person in
particular his life is still very much
evolving his situations very precarious
and there's a responsibility to not do
him an injustice which a lot of his
followers and him said that I did but I
was trying very hard not to my
correspondence with him was to try and
eat from him what I could bring to you
know work the part into something more
empathetic I wanted to meet him not to
study him and then turn him into a
two-dimensional our soul I wanted to
make him somebody who's complex and
human and inspirational and
extraordinary and unique and did who's
done something which is profoundly
important for democracy and I believe I
believe he has and hopefully some of
that is reflected in the film I think
people who are slightly more they know
it's partisan the right word I mean as
in impartial is what I'm trying to say I
did like to say that it was that and if
if anything it was slightly more biased
towards towards his point of view I
don't think it was I think was fairly
balanced but I understand what his I
understood I don't understand what his
his beef was with it quite rightfully
you know was based on two poisonous
accounts to his idea of what that story
was for his experience and to him it was
something that was yeah absolutely
antithetical to everything he tried to
achieve and you know he was dancing on
the on the grave of the
box-office flop that it became but I'm
still really proud of it as a film and
I'm really proud of my work in it and
I'd stand by it if I was off at the part
again tomorrow I'd do it in a heartbeat
I mean to try justify it do justice to a
man like that I think he's the only
Australian I've met or I met but I had
conversation with or heard opinions of
that doesn't think the accents good ever
all that I'm not like him every other
Australia's you know III but seriously
there's a real care of duty and when
it's slightly less I mean that was very
complex because there was a morality
that was very current and it was so
politicized every action of being
involved with it was a political
statement as much as you know he thought
I was sort of working under the auspices
of the DreamWorks / the State Department
I you know as a hired gun I I really I
can tested that in quite a quite a fully
email to him but um you know I feel
strongly as an actor that you should
allow - you should be allowed to try and
dance with these very complex subject
matters and it's tricky because most of
the real people I played as pretty
extraordinary characters whether it's
van Gogh whether it's Stephen Hawking
whether it's Julian during Alan Turing
recently and you know I can you know
what we'll all we do is is the most
light vague interpretation or impression
of these people and their true depths
and brilliance and you know the
cinematic art form in itself is
something that condenses years worth of
experience and moments that stretch out
into boring infinity into a Eureka
moment or a you know a moment of high
drama everything about it is riddled
with complexity because especially when
it's real life you think what goddammit
I know from my research and I know from
talking to this person all from my
reading that it didn't happen like this
and it raises a big question it makes
you go oh why the hell are we doing
anything about real people but yet we
need some access I think some narrative
access to understanding these
extraordinary people in these
extraordinary times so I always look at
it and I this is I notice as a mattered
get out but I do always look at look at
it as a fictionalized truth and I think
most canny audiences know that they
to go to something which has as rich and
complex of subject matter as well yeah
the mathematics of during a
code-breaking or you know astrophysics
and everything that Stephens amazing and
and Julian and computer hacking
programming slash WikiLeaks and
everything that he did you you you
expect people to come to it with a
certain degree of cynicism about well
this is a film of this if I really want
to find out about it it's a conversation
starter it's not a fixed point to judge
everyone by so there's that there's that
as that engagement and then there is
obviously the thing that these people do
still exist and often not all of them
but obviously but not Van Gogh but you
know there is a there is an audience
that already understands these people
through a medium whether it's
biographies or articles or or
documentary so how do you bring about
something that is both new and
invigorating and different but at the
same time has an echo something that has
to be a reflection of these people so
that that balance between interpretation
impersonation is kind of vital and
you're having a really good to
hair-and-makeup team that's always
helpful a good script is also helpful
good directors ultimately the most
helpful you think you could ever have um
and I've been very blessed on that front
well aspirins having spent the last few
weeks going over just about every
interview you've done and all the
profiles I found that one of the edge
that's that's a long week though well it
was did you see your family I mean ah
you have a family in the book not
anymore after that no no it was it was
actually very interesting because you
know they're certain obviously recurring
things that you say but also that that
interviewers or profilers would say and
one of the things in terms of a
complimentary adjectives they they're
sort of a sense that you're timeless
there's something about you you could
have just as easily been dropped into a
movie with Trevor Howard or you know
Peter O'Toole or somebody as as you are
today and blessing of having a weird
face away somewhere between an otter and
something that people find vaguely
attractive or just an otter which is
vaguely attractive
yeah it's I mean I you know on these
haughty lists I just gotta go right
doesn't make any sense because I was
knowing it the thousandth hottest space
when I started out so I know it's I know
a lot of its projection which is which
is kind of flattering about the work I
suppose but what I'm saying all that for
is you know I I started out ya know you
know I'm not I'm not a typical beauty so
basically I've got a long neck and long
face that's usually period that's
usually some kind of inbreeding
weirdness so I'll run with that I wear
some high collars and get on a horse or
two and fine with that but not all the
time not all the gnarled sometimes I'll
just get a collar in the 21st century
drama turning yeah as you'll notice I
didn't sure look so ya know it's I kind
of the or the otherworldly I mean I had
a great great English teacher called
Martin Cyril Oscar you remember him and
he said it's weird you remind me of
William Blake and about what the
hallucinating visionary poets of the
Romantic era yeah we know it's just
you're quite an old soul and I went oh I
kind of like that and that it kind of an
old soul did time and say what as I'm
not a new soul an old soul old smelly
leather self and I kind of I kind of ran
with that because um I was fortunate
enough to grow up in England and you're
surrounded by your heritage then it's a
very deep very long very kind of old
what Harry I mean not my heritage but
like the heritage at the land and the
culture and I went to school where there
were buildings that were 400 years old
and those were the new ones you know and
it was kind of inspiring and it meant
that whatever I was doing in my context
in my time I could always see what the
past had evolved into and realize that
we're not all that far away from that we
really aren't and we you know it's
important to be able to recognize it and
to be able to honor it and and learn
from it as well and I can't remember
your question know as great as get out
it's very hot in here okay um okay so
another another thing that I sort of
jumps out to me about your work from
Sherlock to Tinker Tailor I mean you've
talked about with Tinker Tailor that it
was a particular thrill to work with
Gary Oldman as somebody who you'd really
looked up to but also
sort of mask shifting I think was the
word you use that anyone any actor worth
their salt would enjoy the opportunity
to to be putting on a variety
I mean yeah it's it's it's a gift the
idea of being a spy for an actor is it's
kind of a gift I was half hoping I might
get tapped on the shoulders by mi5 or
six or some one of them and well because
seriously I mean it would be a great
double bluff that there's a bit like guy
Burgess going my party's going I'm a spy
and no one believed in them because he
was but um it's kind of because we're so
sort of you know showing off here's
actors so it'd be the worst kind of
subterfuge but the point is but the
point is we shift masks we do we kind of
do that you know that's kind of what we
do it's part of our job so the idea of
playing someone in one moment in one
context and being utterly different in
the next it's it's meat and drink for an
actor and to do that subtle amount of it
and also in the carries brilliant world
of extraordinary characters and very
real Tomas Alfredson and with the
creative smoke and nicotine that's the
same an alcohol you just dank gray
yellow sort of bad scraggly TV toned
ungraded film well that that film was I
mean you could smell it it was it was it
was very visceral that experience of
stepping back into the past so you know
it felt it felt that there was a contact
with an emotional realism to spying
which is sort of again mean drink
because it's more profoundly something
that's recognizable because they all
have human stories there are things to
sacrifice they will have loves or
passions or prerogatives and moral
compromises and also the sheer boredom
of it the drudgery of it the betrayal of
it all these constantly shifting sands
of loyalty and understanding and
diplomacy and that you know that that's
that's a very rich canvas for an actor
to play with so I I was thrilled when I
got cast and that and with that company
of actors I mean you'd have to
you have to have done really badly to
have done a bad job because it's just
everywhere you look you're being
inspired you know and and Gary in
particular was just a joyous individual
to work with and you know a man at the
height of his game again I think in that
from just incredible incredible
performance so we talked about films
about history or about moments necessary
then you know here's this here come here
someone comes along and says Sherlock
Holmes which has probably been been made
into more plays and I'm sorry more shows
or films and just about anything
yeah it's the most German sighs emotive
fictional time I think I mean so to
somebody says let's let's do it again
we're gonna update it for the 21st
century you know was it immediately
clear to you that this was something
that was a that was worth getting
involved with or when did it become
clear to you that it would work well the
Saudi evolution was that I heard about
it and thought that sounds like excuse
to you know Rhian franchise something to
make money it could be a bit cheap and
cheesy and then I found out who was
involved I thought it's definitely not
gonna be cheap and cheesy these guys are
very good writers I knew Steven my mom
had done coupling a few episodes of that
Sara Alexander's mum and Margate is was
a huge hero of mine as a student with
League of Gentlemen and I just I knew
this table was good and I knew their
involvement in who and I knew what
they'd done with that and I thought well
I gotta read it I read it and I
completely fell in love with it and then
I went to meet them in in a flat in
Holland Park and Sue virtues mother
Beryl virtue once to virtue is called
Beryl virtues daughter but now I think
as you're around she's so strong but
they're both extraordinary Beryl there's
a massive Titan of the industry I'm sure
she's done many of these conversations
she's she is a legend legend and I
didn't but I I don't think I'd ever met
her before so she came in it was her
flat I wasn't aware that I knew I was
being sumac and Stephen and to read for
it and think one of the scenes I did was
definitely the one of the first episode
where I get John to come back to the
flat and I've got I just want him to
type a text for me and I'm sort of
reposed with the steeple hands and and
he's just disgusted that I've said it's
urgent sportin can you make it and he
just comes over and basically as a
secretary for me within the study of
studying pink and and so hosting the
scene
no just before I remember barrel coming
and she had tea and biscuits and I sort
of turned to sue and went is that mrs.
Hanson and she went no that's my mother
okay it's a no good start not a good
start talking forget that happened
forget that happened start again
cancel and continue and I did I know I
made them laugh a bit and it seemed to
go well and you know I knew mark because
well there's an actor we were in start
of a time together and we really got on
so it was fine it was a lot of fun and I
thought this could be great I would
really enjoy doing this just as I was
getting my scooter I got a call from a
jet saying they're really really really
really really really keen for you to do
this and I put my helmet on what finish
a conversation first otherwise that
would've been painful
and I said Christ this could be really
exposing and in a good way but I thought
this is really this is a very iconic
character and whether it's good bad or
indifferent there's going to be a lot of
focus on it as there always is with any
incarnation of the great great
consulting detective so I took a bit of
a deep breath and I thought do I want to
do this is this the moment to do that
because I kind of mean either been other
things hovering around that I might have
pursued or might have done and I just
went no no I I kind of wanted carry on
doing the work I'm doing which is there
it's getting recognition but it's you
know it's just it's leading to the next
job to the next job and I was fine with
that I thought this is a really big sort
of step into the limelight and then I
thought it's really good material I can
have fun doing it we did the pilot it
was great the PBC loved it said one and
a half hours and then that was it and as
far as the the reach of this I mean I've
read estimates they initially thought
maybe two three million people are going
to watch this it was like the they
weren't it blew away from almost the
beginning expectations as far as how
many people cared about what you were
doing was that was that very gratifying
to see well we were all round at sue and
Stephens and we watched it I try to
remember if and I think I don't think
Martin was that something he was doing a
job but we all watched it and I I was
really aware of this immediate audience
response i I don't engage with social
media I have done a reddit but that's
that was it and I really enjoy
but fact the reasons we could talk about
in a minute that would take over my life
and probably ruin it but um I was just
amazed at how vocal and immediate this
response was and it was it was pretty
good it was all very good and by and
large I think I mean they didn't really
the bad tweets and these tweeting and
blogging and just everything just came
alive that was and that's very rare to
have a live experience with an audience
when it's television program it's it was
a new experience for me
I was literally half expecting to sort
of you know walk you know outside to get
the train back from queuing and just and
see like banks of photographers or for
news reporters to be abseiling from
helicopters dogged what was it like to
be a joke and I got that moment was
delayed but um it was very overwhelming
in a weirdly distancing kind of or
distanced kind of way because of us it
wasn't in person but we were very aware
of it being a bit of a hit yeah not
thrilled we still are you talk about
some rules being exposing them there's
another kind where would be I guess we'd
have to talk about the habit with with
smog where I think that there are some
actors who are resistant to the idea of
mocap technology they say you know
what's to stop them from just sort of
using CGI to replace all you know all of
us but it sounds to me from from what
I've read that it was a positive
experience for you that you enjoyed it
and and that you really dove into how
you you know into the process of
actually being very you know the whole
physicality of it also is that is that
correct that it's something you actually
got a kick out of yeah I mean you know a
huge part of what I enjoy as an actor is
is the craft of it the dance with the
medium that you're working in whether
it's camera or stage and the various
different requirements that involves and
you know we evolved a lot of the
language of the visceral visual language
with with Paul and Steve at the first am
do beyond on Sherlock together and it's
it's a collaborative thing and I really
enjoy the technical side of what I do I
like to then after rehearsing and
understanding it and getting something
of a choreography of it just lose my
and discover new things and probably
fall into the camera or whatever but you
know just move away from doing something
precise and precious but I do have an
awareness of it I mean that's that's
kind of what we do I think anyone who
doesn't completely and there are
actually no that's that's rubbish there
are there are moments that I've had as
well where the director wants you to
just completely ignore what's happening
with the camera and just be in isolation
again like Casey just not know anything
about what's happening beyond your
experience of your immediate environment
that being the car self if it's a stage
or whatever the set is if it's a camera
and at the same time if you're doing
stuff that's a little bit more technical
a little bit more visually flaring like
Sherlock is and obviously Star Trek and
and very much smog in mocap you kind of
have to go the distance of understanding
it in order not to hurt yourself
primarily and also just to make it work
make the shot work make the moment work
and and then you can go back and now
step into something that's some
inhabited and this was a completely new
vernacular for me and I didn't have Andy
there to help me although as I joked
you've only done biped mammals and now
I've got to do it serpent reptiles so
you know I don't know how you're working
or translated to small ging but I mean
he is the king of it he's the he's the
Don of it he's the pioneer of it and
he's the master of it and why that man
isn't just literally weighed under with
Oscars is is is it is a sad I think
truth of why it's not being recognized
for what it is it's the unloved child of
cinema because it falls between SFX and
animation and yet it's such a visceral
live performance driven form of art form
of extrapolated cinematic art it's
something that you know green screen you
know I understand
Ian's grumbles about that it's hard it's
really hard because you're continually
projecting all your performance to a
ping-pong ball and there's green screen
and yet you are Gandalf and you know we
were in Gandalf's costume and you're
doing girls voice you go gallows makeup
you again lost continuity but Gandalf
slides well you have you had the lines
at your player the character you're
playing when you're when you're motion
capturing but you don't have the same
context you're in a room
a bit like this fact very much like this
wood panelled you got infrared sensors
all around the roof the kind of core
nursing of the roof you've got this gray
carpet my god I could actually do it now
I won't and you're just you're just free
to position yourself into something
which after you walk on set and you feel
I mean most of you might have read me
saying this before but you feel very
self-conscious because you're in an
all-in-one gray suit and you've got
little reflectors all over you and your
face is dotted in a sort of Aboriginal
pattern of white dots which you have a
you have a caste which in my case was
taken for carne and then that Comcast
was used for my face which was put on my
head holes drilled through it before I
was by my face eyes and then these dots
planted on it so that every facial
movement was kind of corresponding with
a coordinate which they then mapped in
which you get a lot of in the finished
film and you feel like a complete booby
you know you just it's it's embarrassing
you're kind of walking on going hi
everybody I feel silly and they're like
I'd better be great it's if you want a
coffee or sit down we've got a chair
over there it's got your character's
name on it smile so yeah he let's go be
down in a minute so do you want to
reduce or do you want to you know sit
down relax I mean we can you know we've
done the range of motion under that
ceiling you do a range of motion
exercise so you kind of literally move
your limbs your arms your head whatever
limbs your arms our limbs are you know I
mean you move your body to get like a
full expression of what you might do in
the space the volume is they call it and
then your onset being embarrassed and
then Peter comes down he's padding in a
bear figure huh I bet you want it you
want to talk about it or do you want to
do something I mean then what do you
want to do and you go up let's talk
about it first because I'm feeling a bit
silly can I take this helmet off that
has a camera front of my face yeah
whatever you want
cool okay so with this bit the script
and then you work out the intentions and
the actions and the shape of the scene
and the character's motivation it just
all the stud the page one acting [ __ ]
and then you get back up to being you
know fully kitted out bubi and in my
case I'd I'd done a little bit the thing
you said about research so I'm chopping
out that question just for because I
remember they didn't really answer that
I it's a security blanket not all of it
and very little of it ends up on screen
often and it's just to take a little bit
more possession of the extraordinaire so
some of the things I'm asked to do
because it's so far removed from my
experience so it just gets me a little
bit more it just gives me a little bit
more courage to pretend to be something
I'm so far from and so for example
playing a fire-breathing dragon of
however many hundred feet whose ancient
lives in a pile of gold under a mountain
in a kingdom of Erebor
it breeds far you know that's that
that's not my daily routine so I I went
to the reptile house at London Zoo and I
looked at lizards and Komodo dragons and
had some fun with that and then I tried
to work that articulation into my body
so that the boys and girls at weather
would have something to base my kind of
physicality on when they extrapolated it
into the extraordinary finished results
you see they are the best in 48 frames
in IMAX I have to say having seen in
both frame rates that part of the frame
rate thing is unequivocably brilliant I
think it feels I'm artists acting with a
real live and a model or at least you
know at least a model if not a real
dragon I mean it's extraordinary the
seams the seams between the real and the
special effects are just you cannot see
it with that frame rate it's incredible
so I brought that work in to this great
carpeted wooden walled room and thrash
myself about and did voice work and I
absolutely loved that I felt like a kid
again
you know you feel free because you can
only attempt to throw an imagination at
that problem you can't research that
mind you can't read books about when I
was a dragon when I was a young dragon
and you know what happens when you get
crazy with gobble there's a dragon lien
again so I kind of yeah I kind of just I
lost myself in it and I had a really
good time as some of the awful
photographs of me putting really quite
terrifying faces on the internet I've
apparently shown but you got to go the
distance and I loved it I really really
loved it and yeah you know I've done
physical work before I mean Stephen
Hawking and obviously Frankenstein as
well and all my work I tried to you know
we often get criticized as Western
actors as being head down a head up
sorry you know and even though our
verbal culture is a very linguistic
based oral culture very much about the
text in England we do some great
physical work I mean it's you know the
land that Simon McBurney came from to
name but one deviate and all sorts of
extraordinary multidisciplinary kind of
theatre companies as well as you know
dance troupes and everything else so
yeah I love involving that aspect of it
and challenging my body as much as my
head with what I do so that's an
experience where you're working
basically in a room with with a you know
a relatively small number of people I
would imagine then you go to anyway just
drop sorry is anyone else hot yeah I
think it is could we could we turn up
the icon Luke would that be possible
someone's waving their hands but we're
not getting it draft okay so so there's
that kind of an acting expense and
there's then there's the theatre yeah
and you know some it's it seems almost
invariably your actors say that no
matter what the perks of our pleasures
of film or TV acting maybe there's
something really special about going
back to the theatre and that the only
thing that they say maybe sometimes you
know you hear graves but is that it can
become you know perhaps a tad monotonous
but for you you guys with with
Frankenstein with this alternating of
roles and the way you approach it I
think it was such a fascinating thing
and so just generally theatre acting and
particularly in that experience is it's
something you enjoy a lot but very very
very much I mean you know I think the
rehearsal process in theatre is probably
the most kind of privileged part the
whole experience of being an actor it's
wonderful you you have that wonderful
sort of suspended time when it's just a
room there's no one judging you I mean
you're working hard because you want to
please your director but you're you're
with a company of actors and you're
discovering each other and the world of
the play and and how to you know bring
off your partner and that's that's it's
wonderful it's wonderful this it's very
close that it's not what obviously it in
the end is about it's obviously about
sharing that work but
which is always a painful birthing
process like that thing of having the
womb like experience of safety and
security and compounding whatever the
world of that the players and whatever
the requirements are its then you've got
to realize that you've got to then get
on stage or get in front of a camera to
perform it and it was a joy because
there was such extremely different
characters although obviously with the
Matic crossovers and reflections the
creator and the creation so yeah there
was there was a lot of stuff that I mean
on some nights very early in previews
there were literal lines that were cross
again over always on my part I interned
for Johnny's sake he was pretty DLP but
um ya know I love that I really love
that and in fact that was a that was a
complete kind of condition of doing the
job I wanted to do it only if we did
both roles both parts because it's
unique and yeah it's a hard it's a it's
the hardest thing about it it is so
nourishing like I said because of the
rehearsal room environment but mainly
because you have an immediate idea of
what it is that you're doing but it the
real trick and I think again it really
hi heart back to well the Frankenstein
experience but before that we Katie the
the royal court the trick of believing
that you're doing something for the
first time is a very very hard one to
achieve I mean in all honesty there are
very rare moments in the third month of
a run where you're not very conscious of
your audience and the cough that just
happened and what's going on in your
belly and whether you had a little bit
too soon to the performance tonight and
what the hell am I going to do with the
people that can see the play afterwards
and you know that all these outside kind
of voices because you know you it's so
familiar it's so familiar it's very very
hard to trick yourself into unlearning
the muscle memory and it's not like film
whereby you can change your delivery you
can you can give a lot of choices in
multiple takes on on a film so some
actors don't I like to I like to simply
because it's such a rare and an
invigorating thing to be able to do and
that's why I like to mix it up because
then when you go back to film the things
that are weird about film like the early
weird
unsociable hours
no continuity oh yeah exactly all those
all those new problems are compensated
by the fact that you can also not
playing the whole character arc exactly
the constant new thing is a massive
thing you have to really jump in and
notice exactly where you are in your
character's story line but then you can
change you can you can give different
within the parameters like I said
earlier of the tactics your character
can employ to achieve his objectives
through your understanding of the
character and these limitations as well
as its strengths or has you know you can
you can still have quite a broad canvas
to shift things you do in theater but
it's very hard to come in and do
anything more than maybe five or six
very different things and also you don't
want to throw the whole company you
can't go guys um I don't know third
month of this but we just rehearse that
scene we're a little bit worried about
and that's that's hard that's really
hard because it is a job and this is a
job what I do is a job so you know there
are there are moments when it becomes
like a job and you have to balance that
with the craft and the art but you know
it I love it I'm very lucky to be able
to call what I love is an art a job well
before we close with this question from
one of the thousands of people who
submitted questions over Twitter which
you were nice enough to pick the the
winning question I just have to exert a
little editorial privilege and thrown
one more because going this was
something that I know is very important
to you and I think it deserves to be
talked about which is parades end which
was a another great performance of yours
and particularly there's a scene where
essentially you're having to bid
farewell to or just say that you don't
love a person who you do love and and do
the honorable thing over the thing that
might be easier and I just wonder if you
can take us back to that moment because
when somebody was it's like I think I
think the scene I was referring to if
it's the same one is the one in front of
the fender I think is an episode two
where he decides all the hypocrisy of
this invented Department of strategy in
the in the civil service all the
hypocrisy where he's trying to basically
massage the message by faking figures
through the brilliant mathematical mind
that he is and a political mind that he
is he can't do it he just keeps on
seeing no but this is the answer and the
War Office saying nobody can't be you've
got to make it work so that this
is the answer and he goes well just [ __ ]
off that I gotta throw myself in front
of the front line and I'm not gonna I
can't I can't function the way I
function and he meets up with Valentine
who is furious with him for underselling
his ability and also for putting himself
in harm's way because they haven't
consumed what is clearly a blatantly
very strong attraction and she knows
that he might well end his life on the
Western Front and she thinks it's a
waste it's a waste of how he could be
helping and he has to stand up for what
he believes and I it's just it's a
profound it's not it's not very rarely
happy with what I do I there's always
something I could do better it's not
really that it's not really good yeah I
got that right it's more it's just more
bless you it's more who that person is
in that moment and Tom hated it stop it
hated it he was I just feel it's too
on-the-nose it's just I I don't like
doing Christopher has to explain who he
is which is what's brilliant about the
rest of the adaptation is so reliant on
the idea that actors and directors
understand subtext I could read the book
for the most amazing subtext and
profound insight you know into internal
monologues you know literally with
streams of consciousness and this
modernist novel to work their character
into layers that you get a little you
know kind of top mark of and yet this is
a moment where he goes I stand for this
this is what I believe this is what I
hold true to this and I love that man I
really love that Carrington I loved what
he had to say about what he felt England
wasn't what he felt
Society and the duty you have within
society the respect of your elders and
of your past as well as your present to
you know obey and and and help those
above and below your station in life and
you know he supports McMaster who's a
self-made man whose father was a
shipping clerk in some way I forgotten
the line I think it's Liverpool I don't
know but the point is you know he's not
against meritocracy winning he's not
about a fixed social audit but he's
about wherever you are in that at that
given time you better be good to those
above and below you and I just I just
think they're very good principles um
yeah well the last one before we
liberate you is going to come from
Twitter and this is
from Naomi at Cumberbatch web and I know
and Naomi's question was Benedict do you
have a particular motto or creed by
which you try to live your life and I
got a paraphrases it's a Souza quote and
a fan actually sent me a card with it on
the front reasoning it's it's something
like love as love as though you've never
been hurt dance as though no one's
watching you sing as though no one's
listening and live as though heaven is
on earth I just think that's that's
great that's about that's about grabbing
it all enjoying it and um being
profoundly lost in your in your
experience of living on this earth no it
was embarrassing it was I I mean if you
can imagine at the time I sort of I'd
say to my friends I'm doing this film
about a load of girls playing soccer and
it's called Bend It Like Beckham and
they were oh really
that sounds really uncool